let's talk about an issue that's very
close to me
uh and my lineage and my family for some
of you that know or don't know
my mother is armenia diana borussia
if you're listening to this uh first
language i spoke was
armenian and in assyria my dad is
assyrian asori
david the house of david betta surviving
adam netanyahu
and i was talking to the the actor of
the new
movie coming out on uh on apple called
tehran have you guys seen this tehran
tehran tehran
i watched the whole thing i think the
fifth one's coming out this friday
so the main actor has been sending me
messages
for a couple months on instagram and
i've not been following it the main guy
that's
interrogating everybody whose wife has a
surgery all that's a ghost of purse
so he sent him out i'll get to it i
don't i don't know what he's talking
about i honestly have no clue what he's
talking about
then i watch that tehran comes up and
i'm watching like
wow then i see his name coming he said
that's my movie's out have you seen i
said that's you
so what a great job he did acting i was
so impressed he said do you speak farsi
i said you know i can speak 90 i
understand what they're saying
so i speak armenian first language a
syrian second language
farsi third language then you have a
german fourth language and then it's
english i took efl five languages
german i can understand if you speak to
me i can't speak it okay i understand it
but i can't speak it so
armenia and azerbaijan
[Music]
war right now hundreds of people have
been killed
um we are officially on the ninth day
that this is taking place if you're
following this
uh protesting's been going on now for
quite some time in glendale there were a
lot of peaceful
protests going on with armenians
yesterday a few days ago armenians went
on the 101 freeway
on both sides holding up the armenian
flag saying we got to bring attention to
this event that's taking place in
armenia right now
and uh you know eventually yesterday in
l.a the councilman came out mayor
garcetti sent the video they gave a
statement
all of them were wearing armenia masks
if you haven't seen that cat if you want
to pull it up
uh uh counts la councilman armenia
mask if you want to put that up uh it
should show up armenia mask
this was just literally yesterday yeah
right there if you go to images
this was yesterday so they gave a talk
and they all had the armenian mask to
represent what's taking place
um so what is really going on let's talk
about a little bit of the details of
what's really going on i want to hear
your inputs as well with the
this uh challenge so i had a
conversation
with eric israelian who is the producer
of the movie the promise if you've not
seen the movie the promise
you got to go watch the promise the
promise there
this was the last project that
kirkakorian did before he died he wanted
to make sure the story of the armenian
genocide
was told and so he said i don't care how
much money we spent i want to be able to
do this movie
guess who's the leading actor christian
bale he crushes it
if you've not seen it you got to go
watch the promise kai can we put the
link below for people to see the promise
imdb so they can go watch it for
themselves pull up uh i talked to
i talked to eric yesterday for a good
hour when i spoke for good hour eric's a
doctor he's done great things he's also
the producer of the movie we had very
interesting conversations together last
week
on uh sunday i got a call from armenia
with the head of press of nicole
paschinyan we had a good 20 30 minute
conversation together i'm
we're trying to schedule time for us to
interview nicole pacinia the prime
minister of armenia
but let's talk about a little bit of the
events timeline of what really took
place in 1923
stalin when he was the acting commissar
of nationalities
uh for the decided to make a harabak
region an autonomous oblast of soviet
azerbaijan okay
1923 that's what stalin did so meaning
it's the property and under control of
azerbaijan but it's led
by armenians with the community that
they have the current conflict began in
1988 when karabakh armenians demanded
that garabak be transferred to soviet
azerbaijan
from savida azerbaijan to soviet armenia
meaning
it was under soviet azerbaijan the
armenians from kharavak says we want to
be moved over to soviet armenia
why because as the soviet union weakened
armenian population did not want to
remain
within the azerbaijan and declared
independence in 1991.
obviously there was guerrilla warfare
from 1998 to 1991
wasn't pretty was very ugly led to a
full-on war in the early 90s
full-on war and in the late 90s 1991 to
armenians in ghadabak were targeted for
months-long campaign
of intentional civilian bombardment and
blockade by azerbaijan shelling sniper
shooting aerial attacks
killed and maimed hundreds of civilians
you know wounded hurt them a lot
uh ceasefire signed in 1995 by 1994
uh that brought two decades of uh you
know
ward that's going on back and forth a
little bit to stability this is 1994
okay 1994 which is 26 years ago
april 2016 there was a four day
escalation
again war ugliness for four days very
ugly
going back and forth that people dying
left and right the deadliest ceasefire
violation
until 2020 crisis which is now
so now it's been nine days we have two
sides
one side azerbaijani president uh
ilya aliyev who's done a lot of
different interviews lately
he is saying this is our land this is
ours
they're not going to get it and if you
want to come get it we're not going to
let you have it armenia on the other
side
is saying that azerbaijan attacked first
and they started this or many has to
defend themselves and pashinian
prime minister listen we're not going to
sit here and let you do whatever you
want to do to our people we have to
defend our people
so they've gone back and forth and it's
very technical
it's very complicated you know there is
on one end you got armenia
that is somewhat protected by russia you
know the prime minister has had
conversations with the prime minister of
france
the leaders of iran twice he talked to
putin prime minister pashinyan has
and russia kind of protects armenia and
somewhat iran protects
armenia as well because they're right on
the caspian sea and then azerbaijan is
protected by
turkey and also a little bit of israel
because the oil business that they have
in turkey because
turkey is muslim armenia is 96
christian azerbaijan is 91 muslim
population to population i think armenia
is 2.9 million
azerbaijan is 10.3 million armenia's
military budget is like 1.7 billion
azerbaijan's military budget annuals
like 2.9 billion is
twice the amount of military budget so
azerbaijan threatened to attack
armenia's nuclear plant this is going
back and forth it's not really pretty
some of the videos you see
are very very ugly on what's going on
but
russia can stop this but they can't they
haven't yet because they do business
with turkey and they sell them weapons
so they are customers so there are
multiple parties that can stop this but
they haven't yet
us russia and turkey can stop this rider
if they wanted to
but they haven't yet why each have their
own interest
u.s isn't because u.s asked armenia to
stop doing business with iran even
though we put sanctions you still are
and armenia says what do you want us to
do they're our neighbors you want me to
say no to them i share caspian sea with
these guys
right across it we're neighbors i have
to have good relation with my side
turkey isn't doing it because turkey's
never liked armenia
you know turkeys have wanted to make
armenians disappear for the longest time
erdogan cannot stand
armenians is publicly criticize them
regularly
and then on the other side russia is
kind of in the middle saying listen man
we're kind of like the co-chair
and we're watching this with a couple
that different nation that with a coach
i can't fully get involved
but really they can't if russia us and
turkey wanted to stop this they could do
it today but they haven't yet
so that i got more things i want to talk
about with this but i'm going to turn it
over to you guys i know you guys have
done some research as well
sure where are you at with what's going
on i don't claim to be an expert but
you know this thing's only nine or ten
days old but if you look at the if you
look at the history
here's the thing that scares about me
turkey i mean they're the
you mentioned that the fact that they
could they're not going to and they're
right there and they're the ones that
are going to escalate this thing and
make
it make it way worse i'd love to see a
situation where the u.s would would step
in and help out i think that he could
probably take care of this rather
quickly
does the do the armenians have enough
support here to get the attention
of the people they need to to step in
and do something
because i could see one of these this
this is one of those battles that if
you don't have the u.s getting involved
i mean this is going to get bloodier
and deadlier and go on and on and on
unless someone steps in
what do you think the end game is i mean
can armenia
can they defend themselves i mean do
they have the ability over the long term
without some sort of assistance i don't
think so
not by themselves no because here's the
thing they need somebody to back them up
they 100 need somebody to back them up
azerbaijan is twice the size
military budget three times population
wise and turkey 100 percent has come out
and said we're supporting them
no one has come out and say we are fully
supporting armenia like turkey's
supporting right azerbaijan here's what
you need to know about militaries
you know who's the strongest military in
the middle east turkey turkey number one
above everybody exactly so you got the
biggest military back in europe
you need somebody of a superpower to
back you up
and armenia hasn't had that yeah but i
know for a fact
both both the us and russia can stop it
armenia just went into a dealing with
china 15 billion investment going into
armenia so
uss trump is probably not too
comfortable with that and the bigger
concern for us is more iran than it is
anything else
yeah yeah i think the the
the biggest thing that i'm seeing here
is because you know
you might have people being saying well
what do i care about armenia
azerbaijan i've never even heard of
azerbaijan what is it
what happened in world war one did you
really care about what happened in
hungary and austria-hungary and
and serbia but the potential for a
powder keg is what scares me
this is right in the middle east if you
don't know where armenia is and
azerbaijan
it's just north of iran just south of
georgia which is
bordering russia just uh
east of turkey right can you pull off
the map yeah let's pull up a map
but the last thing that we need here is
a powder keg to go off
and the entanglement that's going on i
mean you you were trying to explain it
you have turkey uh supporting azerbaijan
you have iran that's playing on both
sides you have
you have us here then you have russia
that's kind of playing both sides israel
has
relations with azerbaijan because
they've sold them weapons and they have
oil but now you have people
in israel saying we can't support these
people we can't do this the the
the biggest concern for me is this guy
erdogan and turkey
this guy is a strong man of strong men
okay and he's just trying to consolidate
power
and he's going to be the uh president of
turkey for quite some time
and the rhetoric that comes out of his
mouth is actually crazy
and then you have the um how do you say
his name ilham alive
yup this guy so the q i've looked at
some of his quotes and these are the
types of quotes these are the types of
the the way you have to tweet up kind do
you have his tweet i'm gonna read that
this is the type of thinking that is
very
very dangerous i'll wait for you to pull
it up kai he says armenia is not even a
colony
it is not even worthy of being a servant
this is a president of
of azerbaijan yeah this is the type of
mentality
that that you can't even respect your
bordering country
you can't even respect your fellow man
they're not even worthy of being a
servant this is like
this is like when uh you have the
iranian um
the people that run iran what do you
call them the cheeks what are they what
are the people who are
laws the mullahs who says like death to
america they are
less than rodents like this type of talk
this type of mentality is very
very dangerous somebody needs to step in
and whether it's united states i don't
know if it's trump's responsibility or
if this is mike pompeo
secretary of state somebody needs to
step in
and end this conflict before it gets out
of hand and this powder kick explodes in
the middle of the freaking craziest
place on the planet the middle east
sure okay i gotta imagine the armenians
feel incredibly vulnerable
and on on an island like no one's there
to support them right
are they susceptible to china doing more
could china see this
as a way to escalate tension about that
just the other day yes they can see this
as an opportunity for them
to win yeah so my
exactly where you're going is a concern
here's one thing you need to know about
armenians
armenians they're not going to back down
period you know if you go back to
history
i'm half our meaning half assyrian you
know what's the debate on both sides
which one's the first christian
armenians say they're the first
christian the syrians said they're the
first christians but
historically you know say armenians are
the first christians
they are some of the proudest people
you'll ever meet okay
smartest proudest the silicon valley of
russia
is in armenia they are producing some of
the best engineers when we're hiring an
engineer firms and we want to hire
uh uh folks to do coding for us
you're gonna guess your best best of the
best is gonna be in armenia for you
today and this is not just me telling
you this you can go around the nation
and talk to people that you hired to
produce stuff for you
they're going to say we have our
engineers working for us from
armenia they're building that kind of a
reputation for themselves right now in
armenia
however unfortunately
they are in a situation right now that
they need allies
they need somebody to come in and help
them out and
it has to be if u.s comes out
and says hey turkey what are you doing
defending azerbaijan
it is a form of defending the armenian
genocide
erdogan has said if you come out and say
armenian genocide
is an event that actually happened we're
going to go ahead and make sure whatever
we can do to eliminate your three
military bases that you have in turkey
and armenia us has three military bases
in turkey the the
most complicated personality is exactly
who you said
is erdogan listen they can't stand
armenians
they cannot stand armenians to save
their lives
if there is a nation that they cannot
stand it is armenians
but if there is a nation that i can tell
you from personal knowing the history
you you get fighters above fighters
they're not going to back down there's
no way in the world armenia is going to
back down and you're starting to kind of
see a glimpse of it all over the place
by the way here's what's interesting
do you know when's the last time the two
of them were in the same room together
like negotiating right do you know
when's the last time they were in the
same room together
type in uh type in uh elieve
year and a half ago uh uh if you know
how to pronounce uh spell the name
uh right there type in uh uh uh and then
type in uh
uh aliyev look at the just go down and
that name will pop up kai just go down
that name will pop up okay good
and then type in next to paschinian
paschinian january 19 to 20 i think
january 22nd
press images images
gen right there that's january 22nd 2019
they were at the uh
uh davos together having a conversation
a year and a half later who is this
right here that's that's elaive and
that's pashinya
that's armenia prime minister and that's
the president of azerbaijan
a year ago year and a half ago they're
sitting there having a conversation
together okay look at that can you tell
how comfortable that is
yeah the on the right is our armenia on
the left is
azerbaijan he looks exactly like erdogan
by the way
here's the craziest thing check this out
his background just so you know little
details pausing his background
he was a journalist okay
the first company he came out with as a
journalist a year later they shut it
down
then he ended up working for armenia
times for quite some time
and when he was writing he came out
publicly
uh disagreeing with uh disagreeing with
the way
uh the president the military uh leader
at the time was doing
because of that he went to jail for one
year so he ended up going to jail
okay he comes back he's writing for
armenia times as he's going about his
business
and he gets controversial he doesn't
support the first president he supports
the second president
eventually he ends up running democracy
all this stuff
and the closest comparison i'm going to
make to him is trump
let me explain to you why this will kind
of make sense to you so
he's being interviewed by bbc and the
guy from bbc asking me said the reporter
from bbc asks then says
why is it that ever since you got
elected there's so much protesting and
writing going against you
he says because under democracy you can
protest against me
prior to me you couldn't protest against
the president i want to allow democracy
so then i'll say okay but why is it that
when
the the the the what do you call it
they're coming out and telling you
that you cannot be oh it's the back and
forth here you go
he comes out and says why is it that the
u.n general assembly demands the
immediate complete exit
of all armenian forces for from the
occupied territories of republic of
azerbaijan how come you haven't listened
to it he says i'm not going to let
armenians being killed
okay what do you want us to do you want
us to sit around this guy
is a true believer of bringing democracy
in armenia then they bash him because of
covet
they said why is it that the number of
cases you had is six times more than
georgia
and way more than azerbaijan every
single criticism he's getting is the one
that trump had
every single more protesting hey you're
getting more protesting
more covet how you're getting more
covert you're not handling it well right
every single he went to a party that was
taking place
uh during covet and it was 600 people
there nobody was wearing a mask and
everybody's like hey wait a minute how
come he didn't have a mask on he says
because the region i wasn't you didn't
have to you didn't
have to wear a mask and on the complete
opposite side armenia since 1994 has had
four presidents
armenia since 1994 has had four
presidents do you know the same
family has led azerbaijan since 1994.
let me say this one more imperialist
exactly so you got nepotism imperialism
essentially since 94 azerbaijan armenia
for presidents democracy since 1994.
people are choosing their leader
azerbaijan the people are not choosing
their leader so pashina is making the
argument saying listen
the people voted me in but not on
azerbaijan
the families voted people in so what's
this guy's story yeah he's
uh he's from the family lineage you know
he comes from the family lineage and
when you're coming from the family
lineage you're almost like the same one
coming up and
yes yes and his arguments are a
completely different argument says
listen this is our land what do you want
us to do leave our land we own this land
and the land that
is in question is karabakh yes and
for thousands of years armenia owned the
land but after stalin in 1923
uh i think it's 23. yeah in 1923 he said
no we're going to make it over here
to be controlled but the armenians can
live i think the population is 18
armenian by the way in uh uh karabakh
eighteen percent is armenian
yeah that's it yeah it's not as big as
you think but it is about eighteen
nineteen percent of armenian i believe
that's the thing i wanna say one thing
and this is something that i've learned
and i gotta give a shout out to my
friend
tigran becky and we've had many
conversations about
uh everything that's going on here
something you know that that's near and
dear to me
is obviously being jewish the holocaust
right in the 1940s
everything happened with hitler and that
is obviously you know the
what people the go-to story
about genocide that was world war ii but
what people
failed to realize is during world war
one right before that
there was an armenian genocide on the
hands of the ottoman empire turkey
which correct me if i'm wrong they fail
to recognize
they won't even admit wrongdoing this is
something that turkey will not
own up to one thing that i respect about
germany is they've owned up to it i mean
they they have not taken down the
concentration camps they tell people to
come visit they
you know they will not allow nazi
symbols in germany
they know that they messed up obviously
times a billion
what is it with turkey that they won't
even own up to the fact that they've
created
this genocide or meeting people well
and then you're vulnerable to repeat
history right when you have the exact
same beliefs
you know this is a comment that kind of
relates to this but i i wish this would
come up in the debates but
listen to the names that we've thrown
out here in just this conversation china
iran russia turkey us our biggest
problem in the country this country
right now and i wish they would address
it in the
in the debates is we we don't know who
our enemies are
we think it's the democrats for the
republicans or the republicans for the
democrats that's all we spend our time
on
with this bickering and i just believe
this division that we have in this
country
is being manufactured very good point
you know by these bigger superpowers
and if we get thrust into this thing
it's going to be big
because when you look at all the players
that are involved and the area that it's
in
and that's the biggest problem with this
country is we just don't identify we
don't really truly know and identify who
our real
enemies are yeah why don't we do that go
ahead
why don't we do that right now who's
number one right let's stay on this
let's stay on this point here because i
do want to answer your question because
you asked and said armenia
germany germany came out and said you
know hey we did it
okay but they paid a massive price for
it i think their last payment of
reparations was just in 2018 or some
number like that it's just
recently they got done paying off for
all the reparations
and i talked to aram hamparian who works
out of dc representing the armenian
community
do you know what's the number armenia is
going to ask of turkey
if they say the genocide did take place
trillion dollars it's in the trillions
of dollars
this is very basic for them they don't
want to pay reparations
simple as that trillion is a big number
okay you're not talking about a small
number
here it's reparations when the genocide
took place there was a whole insurance
camp going on behind closed doors of
the insurance the people that were dying
their policies that's a whole different
story that had to do with turkey wanting
to get
even more money on the insurance
policies but this is a very
very ugly thing that took place and
all that needs to happen is america
needs to say
it is an event that took place congress
agreed to it senate agreed to it
it went all the way to up to uh
president president said no earlier this
year
and uh uh it's it's uh but again this
year this year yeah this just trump said
no
it's either this year or it's december
but it's in less than 12 months so what
happened with that unpack that from
exactly what i just told you
yeah turkey is an ally of course if
turkey becomes an enemy
nato you lose all control in the middle
east
so the only thing if trump comes out
obama said he'll do it he didn't do it
when he became president
every one of these guys had said they're
going to do what they haven't done when
they became president no one's ever done
it
since they've been president bush all of
them have said it this is an event that
happened to win the armenian vote
no one said yes yet but if trump says
yes
he wins the three million whatever the
amount of people that he's going to win
over right
but he's going to lose turkey and
turkey's a much more
needed ally for him in the middle east
it's unfortunate but that's how he's
processing it
it's not that it didn't happen but i can
tell you one thing it's a money deal
and turkey does not want to pay the
trillions of dollars that they're going
to pay especially in today's money and
they may take them a hundred years to
pay it off by the way
this is not like reparations for germany
against the you know the jewish
community
how long world war one
92 years world war one though that
wasn't uh yeah but you you're talking
about
uh i'm talking about uh uh nazi germany
1941.
okay last one was paid 2010 2010. i mean
that's game changing for two economies
no one paying attention receiving it
exactly so that's the part you have to
realize with that going on so
anyways uh folks if you're watching this
what we're going to be doing is i'll
make an announcement here what's going
on i'll keep i know the armenian
community they message me all the time
on instagram all over the place i'm
getting given text right now for some of
my peers
i want you to know we're in
communication with their camp
uh you know if if my suggestion is
a long form interview to be able to do
with the
armenian pm uh and they can reach out to
us i know even the azerbaijani community
has reached out saying what if
wants to do an interview with you would
you be open to it i'm open to
figuring out a way to stop this ninth
day so it doesn't continue to 10th day
because i saw videos the other day my
friend steve sent me a video kai do you
have that video that i just sent you
can you put it up just to just to kind
of see uh
it's not the worst video i almost
thought about it whether i wanted to
show it or not
but uh you know some of the words he's
saying uh
uh if kai can get this this is probably
in armenian it's the worst
uh uh possible words you can be saying
uh let's see if kai can find it
shout out to steve while we pull up his
clip steve steven
yeah good boy shout out to rafi's place
if you're in la go check that out all
right check this out look at this this
is armenian soldiers
turn that up okay
by the way if you're armenian you're
listening you've got kids you may not
want your kids to listen to this the
profaner is pretty
these are all bodies on the side by the
way i don't know
this is what's going on right now we're
not seeing these are all bodies on the
side and this continues by the way if
you want to pause it you get the idea
yeah i mean he just curses mother out
for what they're doing so
that was which military this is just
this is armenian military
yeah that is going seeing their soldiers
killed
armenian soldiers killed of what
azerbaijan did to them i mean it's a
very
um the the one the one instagram i'm
going to give a
shout out to to go follow uh
uh the uh the population in our talk is
99 armenia today the uh
that lower number is back when the yes
that's right the population art stock is
armenia today back when it was to
azerbaijan it was 18
armenian but today it's 99 percent
armenian that community
okay that's that's the step that i saw
so let me let me give you a one
instagram profile zarton k
media if you can post these guys link
below i kind of want these guys to get
uh
some love because they're getting people
to follow their stories very closely and
i'll give you another update as well
with the stories
for people to follow